هذه إبادة جماعية هذه إبادة جماعية هذه إبادة جماعية هذه إبادة جماعية هذه إبادة جماعية هذه إبادة جماعية هذه إبادة جماعية هذه إبادة جماعية
لا احترام للإبادة الجماعية لا احترام للإبادة الجماعية
لا
احترام للإبادة الجماعية لا احترام للإبادة الجماعية
لا احترام للإبادة الجماعية  لا
احترام للإبادة الجماعية لا احترام للإبادة الجماعية لا احترام للإبادة الجماعية لا احترام للإبادة
الجماعية لا احترام للإبادة الجماعية لا احترام للإبادة الجماعية لا احترام للإبادة الجماعية لا احترام للإبادة الجماعية لا احترام للإبادة الجماعية لا احترام للإبادة الجماعية لا احترام للإبادة الجماعية لا احترام للإبادة الجماعية لا احترام للإبادة الجماعية
لا احترام للإبادة الجماعية لا احترام للإبادة الجماعية لا
احترام للإبادة الجماعية لا احترام للإبادة الجماعية لا احترام للإبادة الجماعية
لا احترام للإبادة الجماعية لا احترام للإبادة الجماعية